هذا مسجد السوق بمدينه وادي حلفا
بات مكانا لمبيت عشرات النازحين من
الخرطوم
المحاميه مي مصطفى واحده من هؤلاء تنتظر
هنا منذ ايام لاستكمال اجراءات سفر
ابنائها معها الى مصر
ان من ديارنا اخرجنا من نعمه ومقام كريم
وجينا هنا بدي اتشرد في حلف الامن منتظرين
عشان ندخل مصر وفعلا لاجئين وفعلا عفشنا
مجدع في الشارع حلفا ايجارات حياه صعبه
قاعدين عيشه بالنسبه لنا ناس طلع من
بيوتنا عيشه قاسيه جدا في انتظار التقشير
احنا الليله ليله يوم 12 يوم لانه عندنا
اولاد كبار وعايزين نتحرك
وصعوبه في الحياه انت بتلقى معانا في اي
اقل ابسط
داخل المسجد يتسابق النازحون على موطئ قدم
للاحتماء من الحراره هكذا يفعل صلاح
الطالب الجامعي في تركيا وقد عبر عن
مخاوفه من ان تفوته الامتحانات بسبب
الانتظارنا في السفاره المصريه لقيت قدامي
الف شخص وفي اليوم بيشيل المياه او اقل من
100 يعني ذي الثلاثه شخصيه الف دانه لو
بنتذرها محتاج يدل حاجه ثلاثه شهور دلو
بالمئه ولو اقل محتاج خمسه شهور ولا اربع
شهور يعني
امتحانات وهتفوتني كل شيء اداره المدينه
شكلت لجنه للتنسيق والتسريع الاجراءات لكن
دون جدوى فالتكدس ما زال مستمرا واعداد
النازحين في تضاعف يوما بعد يوم اللي احنا
بقينا من يوم الاربعاء سلمنا جوازاتنا لحد
الان لم تسهر اي شيء منها
وبكل القمل هاي الوضع الحاصل للناس وعودات
الليله وبكره وبعد بكره ولحد الان ما في
اي جدوى من الاشياء الموجوده في جوازات
ضايعه وما عارفين نتعامل معاه كيف لانك
انت ما عندك ايصال تسليم فلو جوازك راح في
فتره صعبه زي دي يعني مشكله كبيره تقدس
النازحين هنا سبب ضغطا على الموارد
المحدوده للمدينه الصغيره فتضخمت الاسعار
في ظل مخاوف من اقتراب نفاد مخزونها من
السلع الاساسيه
اصبحت الاسعار مضاعفه
والوضع كارثي جدا
كاحتمال خلال اليوم اول يومين الجايه انه
احنا نفقد الموارد تماما
فلذلك احنا بنتكلم بلسان المواطن
الناس تقدم يد العون تنظر للموضوع ده
بصوره جديه ان شاء الله
الف النازحين تركوا منازلهم وحياتهم بحثا
عن الاماني في هذه المدينه
واعدادهم في تزايد بسبب استمرار جحيم
المعارك في العاصمه الخرطوم من جحيم
المعارك الى معاناه الانتظار يعيش الفارون
من الخر يومياتهم هنا بقلق كبير ويخشون ان
تطول اقامتهم فاجراءات الحصول على تاشيره
لمصر باتت بطيئه بسبب الاعداد الكبيره
التي تصل الى هنا حسن رزاق الجزيره من
مدينه وادي حلفا شمال السودان